In this unit, we're going to look at some of the core ideas behind interactive
rendering. First, I'll discuss interactivity, and explain concepts such as the
refresh rate and frames per second. I'll next talk about the human eye and how a
camera works. These both relate to the idea of defining a view frustum as a way
to see into a virtual world. I'll discuss how light travels in the real world
and how we simplify this physical process in our virtual world in order to
rapidly make pictures of it. In the latter half of this unit, I'll focus on what
the graphics pipeline is and how graphics hardware is able to interactively
render complex scenes. I'll end by discussing two rendering algorithms, the
painter's algorithm and the Z-Buffer.